i can't imagine what this man's world
was like
uh over the last three weeks but uh his
team is two and one
they are the defending national football
conference champions and they are taking
on the philadelphia eagles on sunday
football always great to chat
with one of my favorite people that i've
gotten to meet in the nfl
john lynch general manager san francisco
49ers how are you john
i'm doing great i'm i just i came on to
the last part of the aging app i think
being an nfl gm is like
the real life version of the aging app
i mean john have have you reviewed
did you step on any cracks walk
underneath ladders
have you have you have you taken stock
and what you've done and you've and
everybody's how they feel
oh my gosh uh i'll give you the floor
here
on what's happened to your roster you
know you can't play i've been around
this
this game long enough that just it
happens and every year you think well
this is unprecedented
unprecedented it really isn't it it uh
it happens each and every year and you
just hope
um you hope that it doesn't happen you
certainly hope that it's not your team
and
and i think what happened with us you
know you you look back to that jets game
we had some very
you know prominent players and that's
probably been the thing that's different
this year
um there's always guys that go with acls
and stuff but we've had some of the
better players in the league and you
know we had one in bosa
and then there's one play in between and
then solomon thomas
uh does the same thing so you know that
was emotional for our team and
and all that um and we've we've had a
number of other guys
and um you know um
we've uh we've had to use the uh
short-term ir
a little too much this year but uh
hopefully that that settles down and
and uh what i feel good about is the you
know our depth has been tested and our
resolve has been tested and i think our
guys on this late
la last road trip really stepped up to
the challenge and kyle shanahan and his
staff just did a tremendous job of
getting whoever was out there ready to
play and we got two big wins and
and uh you need them all so um
we're feeling good about where we're at
no doubt i mean you want to talk about
character building that that that would
have to do that and also
uh making sure everyone understands that
the next man up is not just a
a phrase like it's literally have to be
a way of life and
you know when you talk about the body
actual actual body injuries it had to
have been out of body than to
to go to west virginia to to go to a
totally
different spot and be there for a week
what was that like
in between games john it was actually
great you know i think back to
we've had uh in the last two seasons uh
three occasions where we've gone we we
went to yongsan ohio
last year after week one in tampa
and then we went played really well
versus the cincinnati bagels and really
got after them
later in the season we lost a tight one
at baltimore in the rain
uh went down to img in florida and um
and you know beat the saints in a in
just a fantastic game down in new
orleans and
and then this year uh we had the
back-to-back new york games and we find
the greenbrier
um you know as a as a place that's had
teams before it's hosted training camps
the facilities are just phenomenal
um and you know we we beat the jets and
then we come and really play well and
and and beat a a giants team and uh
and and did it in a really good fashion
but i i think the theme
as much as we don't like being away from
our families and
and all that the long road trips i think
it gives you a time to get closer
as a team there's a lot of down time you
know when you're in these weeks and
they're busy but just a lot of good time
to to really bond as a team and so i
think that's the benefit we've found in
that
it also gives our coaches you know when
you're at a hotel or at a facility like
that
they i mean they the nights become later
and they're they're genius uh comes to
the forefront so i mean in
in those games are i think they do a
great job of getting our players ready
each week but
it gives them even more time so there
there is some benefit and we've seen to
play well when we've
had the opportunity to to stay out for a
couple weeks
john lynch here on the rich eisen show
and before we get to the here and now
just again
the the the two stints in metlife
stadium obviously a lot was made about
the turf and by
your team and it wasn't an excuse or
anything like that you did come up with
w's i mean did do you still think that
the turf was somehow
problematic negligent even though it did
pass a test
yeah i think our team was was in a in a
rough state they care about
their teammates a lot and uh we had lost
a number of players in that game and
and uh you know i don't think anyone
said something
um that was out of line i think i think
they
said what was on their heart at the time
and uh you know i
i credit the league the pa they all
listened and they went and did a
thorough investigation i think that
helped clear
our players minds um you know there
are some things we can't run from that
hey on
artificial surfaces there's a greater
risk it's just the facts and so
you know jc tretter came out yesterday
and called for
all grass fields i i can't blame them
you know i'm with them in fact and so
i hope that's you know i know over like
in the premier league their players
you know they refuse to play on anything
but it i don't you know i
i don't know if we're to that i hope
someday we can get there
and that's that's uh you know we got to
do everything we can to keep our
most important assets and and uh you
know with the guys that make the game
the players um
healthy and uh you know i think that
would be a great step again you're
referring to the brown
center and nflpa president j.c tretter
in her recent newsletter saying hey
let's have the nfl put only natural
grass
out there no more synthetic turf and
maybe right now
you know when facilities aren't being
used very much then other than by nfl
teams maybe now's the time to do it i
mean do you think that that would be at
all possible
well there's challenges to it no doubt
you think of like sofi
stadium you know a new stadium and that
you know what the challenge there i
would imagine is it it gets played on
every week
you know because you got the chargers
you got the rams and
but i know there's other places you know
um you know in vegas they
you know they roll that stuff in on
trays and i you know i think it can be
done and
i think our league will work towards
that and i i'm hopeful that that we can
get to
a point in in the near future where
that's something we're striving for and
and uh it becomes a reality did you like
playing on
uh you i mean you like playing on grass
more than than the hard stuff right john
i mean you can bring that to the
equation too you know the gm's can't
yeah i hate being that guy but i mean i
played on the whole old philly
the the vet you know the third base
would pop up and
grab you so you know we played on dirt
in fields and stuff so we've come a long
way from there and that's right that's
what makes me hopeful
the old seams right the third base thing
oh yeah
i remember that was one of the most
famous moments in hard knocks history it
was like
when uh the ravens and and bilic would
go up went out there and
and basically said we're not playing on
this thing right now but obviously that
we
we've come a long way and um i've got
john lynch here
on the rich eisen show and not not to
turn you into a news uh anchor an
updater but you do have a ton of
information that
i think a lot of fans want to know uh
about
your players uh kittle's back at
practice correct so he's going to go on
sunday night
right we're going to see kittles
kittle's done a great job um
you know like he does in everything in
life just attacking his rehab
and and he he's looked good out at
practice and we're hopeful that that
continues to progress
in the right direction so it's going to
be great to have george out there james
g what about jimmy
what about jimmy g what do you think
jimmy did not practice yesterday
um you know we'll see if he if he uh
transitions in
into practice but uh right now it's
looking
like uh it might be another week but uh
you know
also we've got a little extra time with
the sunday night game and so
you know we'll jimmy jimmy's going to do
exactly what you'd expect him to do he's
a tough kid
plays with the tremendous mentality and
um you know but
um he's working his hardest and and
there there are some issues with that
ankle where it's just tough
and and he'd be compromised and will
never put him in a position where he's
compromised out there
what about uh okay what about we're
going what about raheem
what about raheem i think still
questionable he's he's working hard he
was out running to the side yesterday
um best thing for the most they had a
new baby boy last week and so we're
thrilled for them and
uh he got to he got to be home and see
that so we're uh we're happy for them
but uh you know in the midst of that
he's been dealing
with a little mcl spraying he's working
hard to get back and
and i think questionable is the best way
to to term his
status for this week what about richard
sherman what about him
john we see sherm is still on the short
term ir
so uh has another week he's eligible to
return
next week and uh that can he can open
his practice window but he's he's doing
well
and um you know we he's such a great
player such a great presence for our
team we're we're eagerly
awaiting his uh his uh return you know
the thing about him he's
uh so much said about richard and i've
always had the utmost
of respect i've known him back when he
was a receiver at stanford
um and uh you know
i tend not to listen to all the bluster
but watch what happens and he's always
just been a great player
and what we found here is a great
teammate he
cares about his teammates and i think
that shows when you aren't out there
he's still leading these guys so
it's it's been awesome having sherm
around and and
uh we can't wait till he's back out here
playing with us and again i apologize to
continue to just to turn you into
like a who's up who's down but i mean
your star player i mean the number of
players i don't need to obviously remind
you but what about debo samuel when do
you think he returns
to the was on the practice field
yesterday and uh it was very encouraging
he's worked
very very tirelessly to come back i know
he was disappointed that he didn't he
he wasn't there from the start of this
season but you know i think uh
we had to be smart about that he was on
the practice field yesterday looked good
if that continues to
uh to to to go in the right direction
there's a chance he could be out there
um you know this this weekend so uh
we're very encouraged where debo samuel
is
and d ford is headed to ir correct he's
or he's there he's
likely likely he's struggling with you
know with some of that back stuff and
and uh you know that's that's that's
difficult so he's he's struggling there
and likely going to be
the scenario where he can go to the ir
and
um you know because of covid we have
that three-week ir at our disposal and
you know it's helpful in situations like
that to be able to get a guy right
and so you know we're just we're just
praying that the
uh you know can can reverse kind of what
what's going on right now and can get
back out there and help us he's a
fantastic player when
when he's on the field do you need me to
light a candle for you so all religions
can pull together john i mean like
i mean can we i just i mean just do do
you have like a story that you could
tell
us about how deep down the rock like
your your lists of people to keep an eye
on that you
that you've gone over the last two three
weeks at all or no
i mean well you know i think the one
thing
um first of all you know i think i'm
real proud of our staff the way
they've been finding guys to come in
here and and compete and play and and
the depth of our team
has been tested but i think we've
answered the bell
um and you know i i think
the if anything fortunate about what
kovit has caused the league to do we've
got a bigger practice squad this year so
that's
that's allowed us some things we talked
about the three-week ir it's given you
some flexibility to be able to maneuver
around and
um but more important than anything is
just the mindset that hey you can't feel
sorry for yourself your opponents sure
aren't going to and so we've got plenty
of players we got a lot of players that
are very very capable we went out and
showed that the last couple weeks and
we'll continue to do that
and not use you know the
you know something that's really been an
issue around the league right now a lot
of early injuries as a
as an excuse it is what it is and we got
to go fight through it
and that's the mindset of our team well
you know me john that was my way of
fishing to see if you were
looking at me for a speed position in
any way shape or form
that was my way of saying how how close
was i to getting the classroom
so you improve every year thank you
that's what i was
that's really all i was looking for
right unbelievable uh and but before i
do let you go
uh i want to give you the floor on
what's going on um
in tennessee and how you might use this
as a
you know i don't i guess i say
cautionary tale
um not not to imply anything about
tennessee
uh they're following the protocols uh
we're assumed just like everyone else
and it happens
this is there's just no way i guess to
prevent it i'm wondering what you're
you're thinking as you you know about
your
your colleague and john robinson there
and obviously this team that's three and
oh
uh what do you think of when you hear
this news out of tennessee john
well i i think um that what the league
has done to this point
has been a remarkable success i mean the
uh
the the um the lack of
of infection rate and and the way that
everybody has taken on this challenge
which is it's a monumental challenge
rich the protocols that have gone on
we're asked to do do more with less
people
and i can't tell you enough about our
staff and the people who have worked
tirelessly and that that goes around the
league and i
i know john robinson and the titans have
done their best and
i don't think in these you know it's a
pandemic so it's no one's fault
um but i think what this has caused is
you know you need
these cautionary tales to um to remind
everybody um that we have to remain
vigilant and
and um and then it also has said okay
let's
let's uh plan for the unforeseen and and
hopefully
that that never happens to us but if it
does happen how are we going to respond
and so
that's what this year i mean that the
amount of time uh spent and things that
are non-football
uh has been an all-time high but that's
that's what the job's calling for right
now and
and uh we'll continue to face that and
you know the league's doing their best
to
to try to keep everyone safe and and i i
really think they've done an outstanding
job as have
the teams and so this is a little bump
in the road and
not something anyone wanted to have but
um i think they're doing the best they
can given the situation
john best to your family always
appreciate you taking my call
and coming on here i do always enjoy our
chats and catching up
with you i always enjoy being on with
you thanks a lot rich and best of your
family same to you that's john lynch
general manager of the san francisco
49ers hosting the
philadelphia eagles on sunday night
football from what
appears to be as we're sitting here
right now with big nick mullins getting
another start
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here